hold on to your butts things are about
to get really weird you know liminal
spaces liminal spaces
of liminal spaces
[Music]
isn't that a little unsettling
something's odd about the liminal spaces
there
well
[Music]
you notice how something as innocuous as
a radio can be slightly unsettling in
the wrong place my leg is on fire
I'm not going to explain why except that
I'm going to explain why have you ever
heard of a thing called Tiger Bomb well
it's basically pure Menthol uh and so
when you rub that on your leg it uh it
has a cooling effect but also
hey my leg is on fire I did it because
my leg was sore
wait a minute
the back rooms
oh my God
um
anyway I had a cramp in my leg and I
thought hey I'll try this thing that um
Phil uh the DP told me if you don't know
what DP is stop laughing it means
Director of Photography he told me about
it and he bought me a little jar
so I just rubbed it on my leg and it is
really intense take
why would I take this
oh yeah
you remember how I said that you were
gonna
blow your gourds all over your computer
screens or your phones or whatever
you're watching this on
oh yeah that's what this game is
that's what this game is all about
you think you know his face no you don't
holy crap oh my God
oh I don't know I did not do that right
oh my God
that is so cool
that's so cool you can't deny that's
cool but I messed it up so it's not that
cool but it will be cool once I get it
right
that's nuts though
that's so cool Wham
oh what wait a minute
oh crap I fell past the frame I was
falling past
um
am I dead
I'm dead
oh thank you
this
this is the beginning of something
beautiful this is the beginning of
something
hello oh door must be upright well it's
kind of
it's not kind of well come on it has to
be upright
it pretty much was upright already but
whatever
all right I'll do it normally
if we want to be boring like that oh
oh ah
interesting
what if I cut right through the middle
there
Wham
what hey
wait a minute how dare you break reality
when I'm in the middle of breaking
reality
oh you think that you're too clever for
me I picked that up
okay so how do I um uh
oh boy
um ah it's just a rope is this um
it's a cross section did I not do this
right
uh can I go this way
I go this way
no I did not do something right look
oh
ah try to contain yourselves I know it's
getting wild ooh decease your I don't
want to go I don't I don't know if I
want to go to that room I don't know if
I want to go to the room of Eternal
mannequin judgment
oh
ah
um oh my God
oh I might have goofed it I might have
goofed it
yeah I goofed it maybe let's sneak
through there and then you guys are
gonna judge me but then you're all gonna
fall down
or you're gonna stand there ominously
are the walls moving
okay thanks guys
hey look friends oh God I caught you in
half
or not half all right that's a it's a
lot more than half but we're just gonna
round up and say that I cut you in half
oh
okay and one more aha sorry gang
oh boy I don't like this
I don't like it
I could where am I going
okay oh sorry
I'm uncomfortable
I don't feel good about this
these are circumstances that I don't
enjoy
I'm gonna exit
oh do I want that oh oh okay
what if I just what if I what if what if
I What if I
oh no oh no no no no
what if I just what if I what if I just
good
okay this wasn't useful at all I don't
know why I did that
um
uh
well it was fun you know
very unisonous but um didn't really help
me get to where I needed to be
wonk
well that does spiral often oh
sorry I need to get the staircase so
that I can get to that other thing
because then I'm gonna be able to get up
high enough to be able to actually grab
it
that's using my noggin that makes so
much more sense and definitely explains
that I wouldn't have been able to
survive if I did it any other way
alright so I don't know how particular
my placement can be for these stairs
uh
I mean
looks pretty good
oh maybe
oh oh
uh
oh no
oh
damn it all right so I gotta place this
where the painting is not going to
intersect but the staircase is still
going to be tall enough that it's
actually going to be able to help me
three two one boink
I hope
yes
yes freed freedom freedom wait free wait
freedom
freedom freedom
Freedom that's so weird how they do that
that's so weird the perspective is so
freedom
Fred freedom
freedom freedom freedom
what is that
it's a rock guys it's a rock
guys your bush
I got a tree oh door all right
I know I'm mostly stupid but um I don't
mean to be that stupid are there faces
in the wall
they're ominous music on the Wind
is someone splish splashing in the bat
am I
am I I'm in the water
how long has that been occurring man my
leg tingles
it's dark
liminal
liminal liminal liminal liminal every
time I say liminal put up another
liminal photo oh
not very liminal
this is terrifying though I don't like
any of this oh
ah
hello doc hello tree
Hello Duck and duck two
or duck three
I got a good feeling about this
everything's gonna be a-okay
I can tell
nice boat
a nice boat oh I see
watch this Wham
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
ah oh
Elixir go ahead and you you
see that spider right lexian
kill Nixon kill
God damn
oh
thank you
thank you Alexander your blood in my eye
that was an overreaction
I'm not afraid of spiders
but I don't like the fact that that is
now reality and the painting's now gone
a good skitter across the ground God
I really thought
they were gonna make a banana girlfriend
like oh man oh man tryptophobia banana
oh
I know it's
whoop
again
the genius move would have been behind
me but I'll I'll give I'll I'll give
credit where credit's due
because that whole setup was very good
but the pro level 99 IQ move 900. I
can't move whatever down there
anyway
all right
oh boy oh oh
whoa
ah oh okay oh good
oh good
how are you
oh
[Music]
I'm having a wonderful day thank you
you guys seem a little three ah
is this like I'm being observed for
utilizing powers that I could never
possibly understand or something you had
way too much
all of you did
all of you did oh hi
well I don't exactly know how I'm gonna
get up there I'm just gonna Trust
I'm trusting okay good good good
great good
good
is that a camera
do you need me Worthy
you trust me with this
I sure did
whoa bam
I shouldn't have wasted that
oh wow I made an even darker hallway
oh good
oh great
um
oh
of course
that's
that's nuts
oh oops well I have this still I don't
know why I still have it I don't know
why they let me have that but I have it
uh that's nuts
that's nuts
this is crazy
this is nuts
all of VHS never mind it's film
I thought we were gonna watch a grainy
movie
this
that's kind of well shoot I keep
forgetting what rotate is not r
this this is
I mean God can you the game implications
man
there's this
what do you
do what do you even do it's so cool
this is epic so you gotta like think in
terms of brain breaking methods to like
bring
these pillars down so oh frick I did it
again
um yeah you gotta bring the pillars into
place so that you could have them close
enough to be able to actually get where
you need to go
like let's say for example I just wanted
to like create
this kind of bridge because I want to
get up there later and then what I do is
basically I could utilize the same
stack but a better exposure of it
so you gotta like get a I'm on a more
longitudinal longitudinal one so I got
that
that yeah yeah yeah
oh that's crazy
[Music]
that's nuts
ah not quite though not quite oh that's
nuts that's
nuts
uh oh that might be too offset oh maybe
oh maybe oh maybe come on
yeah
yes wow
that also was an overreaction
I apologize for nothing there's one
thing I do it's overreact I have a
license for it can I please walk up this
it really wants to slide me off
oh wait I didn't do this right oh wait
yes I did because I just need to take a
picture of it I don't actually need to
be near it
we
all right and then God damn it
well this cleans it up a little bit so I
don't have to worry about it being all
kinds of Jank Wham look at that door wow
nice door this
this is crazy
right this is crazy you all can see it
right
you all can tell what the deal is here
why this is oh my God
I knew it was gonna break my brain I
just didn't I did it again
oh oh actually that's that's how you get
extra film I guess
man that's not
so cool
this is so cool
I only needed two for that
easy
Wham
wow
freaking awesome
that was not an overreaction that was a
perfectly reasonable reaction to
suddenly falling to your own demise
so I will not take any crazy criticism
why did my why did the floor go goodbye
why did the floor go
why the floor go bye-bye
why
oh man it really doesn't want me to get
up there
I'm afraid of making the floor go
bye-bye
if I get up here oh never mind I'm
almost good ah damn I should have gotten
that one maybe I could just take another
picture
damn what is it up there yeah that's
that's fine yeah No One's Gonna mind
that
that's not a problem
okay so I need to bring you even closer
get up there by doing that and then wham
wham bam
it's like that and then I can get really
close to yous and then look at that I
got a door possibly anyway let's see
Baba dub
boom
oh
oh oh nope nope nice
I love this
uh if I if I can I make these doors can
I make the gaps in this fence really big
if I take a picture really close of one
of these
can I make this like extra large gap is
that possible
oh my God
what that is not
that is not what I expected to happen
Okay
um oh wow I oh I did not do that right
but I love my strategy I think my
strategy really really meant something
um not sure what but it meant something
all right hold on guys I'm gonna try
that again
uh
uh boom
interesting fascinating
weird can I like take a jump pick
what would this do what is this gonna do
for me what here we go
oh
oh I didn't actually capture anything
important so I didn't
I'm just gonna be spiraling off into
constant chaos Dimensions here
oh my God
oh God I'm lowering the resolution as I
go
oh it's a nightmare
oh it's a never-ending nightmare
oh my God this is awesome
oh no I've broken so much
I know I should just restart but I'm
having God look at this look at this
nonsense
look at this look at this nonsense
look at the nonsense
oh
what have I done oh hey wait a minute oh
wait that's just oh that's where I
started oh okay all right that is so
freaking cool I love this I love this so
much
what I'm gonna do
I've got this I've got this okay so I
need a picture of long hallway
with with I'm gonna get with this so I'm
gonna put this here get as much hallway
as I can okay I don't want to blast
right through this
to go wham right through
then I'm right through and if I jump up
here I am oh not quite through
I'll do is I'll take another picture
of this and a boom and then let's carve
through again right
there but I want to be able to get up on
it oh crap
like is tunneling in Minecraft okay I'm
not doing this right I know but I'm I'm
bear with me bear with me what would
happen if I just took a picture of this
like that
would that do for me
what about oh yeah what if I just like
that
would this work
oh almost almost not quite but almost I
actually like that idea
that's pretty cool
oh maybe if I take a picture this way
it'll have more like Darkness at the
other side of it and then I can control
more where that's going to go
I mean yeah you know what I mean if I
just do this
and then I
kaboom
and I go up and I go over and
then I just take a nice Whoop I'm gonna
take a nice jump pick of this
nah I gotta get more I gotta get another
one of these this is all do it
yes I'll fix it don't worry guys I got
the solution to everything this nonsense
it's gonna go up and around up and
around up and around there we go boom
M all powerful
I am all powerful oh interesting
fascinating
okay all right
really do got to just think about your
composition here
if I just take this staircase I am bring
it up here
and I make it more like that and I go
kaboom then suddenly I've got St oh that
might not make it oop I should have
gotten another picture
I bet there's like one picture you could
take that would get you all the way over
there I got it
it's the secret was here all along
oh
oh I put way more depth than that than I
thought I did I broke the door so hard
that is so much so the depth that you
capture in your picture does reflect
on the depth you put into the photo
later that's good to know because then
this whole ceiling is actually
pretty much all I need is if I just go
like
let's just say yoink
plop
I'm up climb up climb up climb up climb
up so close oh my God
uh
I
I love this I love it it's not often
that you experience a game
like even even one of these short well I
mean there's more than a demo this is a
whole game by itself but it's just like
or you see something that you've never
really seen before and it kind of
tickles you in a way that you're like
holy this is crazy
because really this is crazy
this is super cool I'm not 100 sure how
to deal with this
I gotta just climb up but I don't know
how to just climb up especially with
this big dildo I just took a picture of
uh I guess I could kind of just
blood out and see if that'll allow me to
climb up it do it do but not very well
if I took a picture this way it actually
might help me
extend this
but again not really the perfect
direction of where I'm trying to go
but it is up so that's something
is gravity gonna flip you know when I
get high enough ah that too steep
that's too steep damn it
try this again but this way
oh damn
uh not quite there we go
okay so I think it's safe to say gravity
is not gonna flip for me even though
that would be really really cool and
awesome
totally rad
it just really doesn't want to it's like
that can curve up in that way well that
is limited but I need a gap something to
close this Gap a little bit
oh maybe this will do
there we go nice nice is there something
in there that I need to take a picture
of that I could then bring down because
this is
I am oh interesting how in the frick am
I supposed to get up there
I don't
oh careful okay it's getting a little
tricky
probably could have done this a little
easier but I
didn't
and
nice
oh careful
careful now
okay so gravity definitely not going to
flip but I don't need it to
I have spiral geometry out of this
universe
I do not regret a thing
careful careful now
oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God okay
I'm just gonna try to oh my God
it's gonna be really careful about this
gonna get me over there oh I'm so close
I'm right there if I grab another
picture of this maybe I could maybe I
could snake it up to where I need to go
just sure I need to go over there now so
I think it's okay if I just kill this
you know and go for gold here Wham
okay all right
got that so I think I could just
think I could just do this
my brain is broken this is
God
God look what I just did
nope this is awesome hey is that a goose
maybe I shouldn't do this but I'm doing
it oh there's a color of goose is that a
goose or not
whoa
is that a goose cation whoa
impressive
oh again with you bye geese
oh oh shoot oh shoot
oh shoot
we're okay
did the music stop for okay
I thought the music stopped for like a
story reason and something terrible was
gonna happen but um
everything seems to be fine I've got my
Godly camera Powers everything's good
everything's good
what are we doing here
staircase but I don't know if it's not
gonna actually have a door in it
weird
so that's almost slightly different in
that it has additional geometry from
just being a projection like actually
something more
oh do I wanna do this
is this a good idea ah frick I'm doing
it
yeah all right let's make the moon just
a little bit
bigger let's make this a little bit just
a little bigger oh hold on a second
also it's the same size moon but
I
I don't know if that's what I oops oh I
forget how to rotate every time
okay so I'm just gonna put the the try
moon in ah
that's not right
that's what I was supposed to do
Ah that's that's about whole Moon I
don't know if this is what I was
supposed to do
in fact I'm pretty sure I wasn't
supposed to do this
shabam
oh
um
maybe I was just supposed to get more of
the night sky so that I could see
outside of this and not create many
moons
many many moons
um
I see well I mean I don't oh man I I'm I
should reset that because I don't think
I'm supposed to make the million moons
oh I know what I need to do oh it's so
obvious
of course
let's do this
I'm going to the Moon
oh my God
Moon uh
oh
[Laughter]
I love it
I love it hey why is there another Moon
over there
oh that's the moon that's not the
picture Moon that I took a picture of
that's just another Moon I love it I
love it
I love it
I love it I loved it I love it I can
Forest I love it
I loved it excellent work fantastic work
actually if you think about it that's
super cool I can't overstate how cool
that was I don't know if it'll like last
the coolness over like a multi-hour game
but for a demo uh pretty cool so thank
you so much for making it and thank you
everybody so much for watching it hope
you enjoyed it let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
hopefully there'll be more to this game
or this type of game in the future thank
you and as always I will see you
bye-bye